we use two years olds just now how big
results to prove a trigonometric
identity we saw that was useful if
you're like I don't know what else to do
here
can't see the trigonometric identity
that will be useful a substitute here
I'm just going to go to a draw
okay it made the working longer but it
also made the working sort of mentally
easier you can just saw your spare
brackets and simplify fractions and do
all the algebraic manipulation stuff
that you're already quite good at this
is a different kettle of fish I'm not
proving a trigonometric identity I'm
solving a trigonometric equation now
again I'm putting our cherries off
because at the moment if I just handed
you this the method you have currently
have actions to you are not going to you
they're just not enough like what can
you do with this thing I showed you to
make a greater than quite messy before
you've known where you can sometimes say
if this was saying
squared what could you do in this case
what difference but it may actually
dramatically simplify the question even
on square that's in a little while can't
sort of frightened brain a little bit
this is a not a quadratic equation but
it's reducible to a quadratic equation
if I replace sine squared with 1 minus
college squared remember I can do that
because the paths are going underneath
there you've got some close queen Tiye a
card there this is a quadratic
Ian connect and then you could solve
okay however I've been eject and I'm
hitting there all right so what are you
going to do okay on top let's see if t
results can help us I'm going to be you
just like I did the whole by introducing
the T results if this is true I now have
access to all that to T or 1 minus T
squared blah blah blah stuff that I
established
so let's see what happens there for five
or decide it's you've got on your page
what's it actually equal to 2t 1 1 1 1
plus C square - what's cos 1 minus 1
minus T squared on it's the same
hypotenuse remember that apparently it
is equal to 2 now just like before
because this denominator comes up so
frequently I want to get rid of
fractions so I'm going to multiply
through by this denominator okay
once I do that this is becoming come
this this is going to become this and
this is going to become this has look
you can tend to that multiply through
little fractions great and if I can
triple 5cr
this is just a quadratic just the
quadratic you know I said before are
cool to the squared I can tell you
quadratic key results allow you to
access everything you know that
quadratics even one what you start with
is one so let's go ahead I've got to t
minus just watch your double negatives
there 2 plus 2t squared does look at
rate as a quadratic we're going to
everything on one side looks like the
right hand side my big E's hundred to
put it so I'm going to have how many t
squared left on the right hand side just
one of them how many T's like it I'm
going to subtract 20 from both sides
foot - 250 and then how many years let's
consider an area yes so then the two
already and I added one to both sides
that's the zero okay this is great
because it even though it's not easy to
factorize it easy to solve right I can
watch it record rate formula so what
quickly this is going to be minus B plus
or minus the square root of what v b
squared b squared minus 4ac which in
this case is one for a C is 12 isn't it
yeah what was divided by
today which in this case is just - all
right just a little bit of numerical
work here 100 take away 12 is 88 s
divided by 2 and then I can simplify my
certain here a little bit by saying
that's 5 plus or minus this is reform
the bottom right 2 is equal to root for
so route 88 divided by the root for 2 is
route 22 you agree I can clue a couple
of extra steps and gear but I'm not
worried about assert if you want to put
extra line in there just discriminative
fun but that's step steep ways that
informs taker can x1 to x2 that's really
what I've solved it 5 plus or minus 3 22
that's a gross number of course it's
course could look at this thing how
would I supposed to solve it if it was
an exact value what is really the key
results
so now reach for your calculator in
order to get not 10 an X on to by just X
on to you're going to take each of these
numbers 5 minus root 25 plus root 22 and
you can go [ __ ] and should give you
some numbers now I've already Percy but
you can tell me if I got something like
I've got 17 point to dozens of degrees
or a four point one degrees someone
quickly check yep is it work out okay
now I did actually want X on to I wanted
X so what I do if I thighs in order to
get X you just got right so this is
thirty four point four and this kind of
will be a hundred and sixty eight point
two just got to check your decimals
I bet use all the solutions that the
effect between north and 360 they our
next lesson we're going to get to how
you can do that you got it right but
just let me just to continue because
we're going to deal with functions like
this let me prove that this is actually
that this graph is five side x - context
looks like that you see that this graph
here is a graph that is five sine x -
product can you see how it goes really
high see that why is that so high we're
usually earlier between negative one and
one because the best part about the
front knee changed the Ethel to you
right it's not exactly five I'll get
into that later sweet now I'm going to
put on - why is two relevant point
because that's what I'm trying to find
where did he go - right when is that
equal to and you can have a look the two
doubles are found 34:44 and 158 point to
that there are your two point two the
second